i'm sorry i have to tell you the council
of america
this is my last day in america
can i give you one last hug natalie
the moment it's here the moment we've
been waiting for
which i honestly feel bad for saying
because
it turned out to be way worse than i
thought mike called off his wedding to
natalie
the day of the ceremony when just hours
before
he seemed to be looking forward to it i
just couldn't do it
tomorrow yeah we're gonna do it okay
was mike wrong for changing his mind at
the last minute
or did he ultimately do the right thing
we're gonna talk about it as we take a
look at how it all went down
plus stephanie and harris i know i've
talked about them
almost every week now but these two trip
me out
stephanie had harris do a reading with
her psychic maria
to see if he's genuine is it okay if i
just
respectively just ask you a couple
questions mario
ready for any question a sidekick
that don't fear in me well i don't know
if it was the wine or the reading but
something had him sweating
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
this was an episode that they've been
teasing
since the beginning of the season yes we
knew mike eventually was going to send
natalie back home to the ukraine
but i didn't think it would happen like
this let's go ahead and take a look at
what took place
the day before mike called off the
wedding
you ready for those you ready try this
yes all right
they both were in good spirits at dinner
mike was even eating some
i don't know what this is but it looks
vegetarian
which i'm sure natalie was very happy
about because
we know she's been pressing him to eat
better oh my god this looks delicious
hope it is slaved away all day um
wait what was that about mike natalie
was opening up about her feelings and he
definitely gave off that
i'm uneasy next scratch look then when
she said she was really happy about
where they are
he looked a little stressed at this
point
yes i am looking for all the signs that
he was going to call this thing off
because verbally he was talking like
everything was just fine
there was even this really cute moment
where he gave natalie a lap dance
because she won't be having a
bachelorette party
i think anyone that has gone through a
k1 visa um
yeah 90 days is a lot of pressure it's
very fast but
we're both just really really excited to
get married
and it's just great all around so what
happened between that night and the
morning
that made him realize that he just
couldn't do it that's what i want to
know
if i was natalie i would be dealing with
some major
trust issues after experiencing
something like this
it would be hard to get excited without
worrying in the back of your head
then you're going to be let down this
woman literally ended her night
thinking she was about to be a wife and
woke up to mike telling her
uh uh not today hello
[Music]
mine
okay slow down because i can't i can't
understand what you're saying
slow down i'm sorry i'm sorry just funny
natalie went on to explain to the
wedding officiant that mike woke up
and told her that he's been thinking and
he's decided that he can't
marry her which of course is sad but
i think the savage part of it all is the
fact that she only has
three days left in america and because
of the coronavirus
the ukrainian borders are closed so
she's not only
not getting married anymore but she had
to find a way back to her country
during the height of a pandemic well you
have to go back home that doesn't mean
the relationship is over it's all that
i'm sorry i'm not discussing it with you
i cannot forgive him this
he loves i understand you know they say
when you don't listen to the signs the
first couple times
eventually they will come knock you
upside the head until you have no choice
but to see them
as natalie was packing she took her
anger out by throwing mike's shoe
because she was quote mad we also
learned that he is paying for her ticket
to go to europe
but once she gets there she has to
figure out herself how to get to ukraine
before we get into whether or not mike
was wrong for all of this
let's take a look at the emotional
moments coming up for them next week
i don't know what to say
i'm leaving america tomorrow i i'm
honestly freaked out
and scared i have to do it because i
only go here
i'll give you one last hug natalie no i
cannot michael
i cannot why you do this you think
was mike wrong
of course i think most of us can agree
on the fact that
what he did was very selfish that's a
given
at the same time
i can't fault him for following his gut
i would rather him call off the wedding
than marry her and file for divorce down
the line
it seems like mike wasn't ready to make
things official with natalie
but he also wasn't ready to let her go
for good
which is a hard place to be in
emotionally
according to mike's friend tamra he was
crying when he broke the news that there
wasn't going to be a wedding
sometimes breaking a person's heart
hurts more than actually getting your
heart broken
so although he should have handled
things differently
this obviously wasn't an easy decision
for him to make
that's probably why he dragged it on so
long literally to the day of their
wedding
that being said he also should know not
to ask natalie for a hug
mike you did your damage now just let it
go
all right let's move on to stephanie
harris and her psychic maria
i've said this before and i will say it
again
i think maria has a good heart i think
she wants her friend stephanie to be
happy
but this guidance y'all i'm not sure if
it's really been helping stephanie
okay so where do you see yourself with
stephanie in a year or two years
well my hope in this relationship with
stephanie
i wish she can take me home so i can be
her
bodyguard taking care of her yard
everything taking good care of her
future the right way
ryan he never made mention of you it was
always what he what you were going to do
for him
i like you i like your eyes you got kind
eyes i think that this could be your
night
shining armor what set of eyes is she
looking at in night and shining
armor even harris seemed to be surprised
by maria's reading of him
stephanie really takes to heart
everything her psychic says
so now she thinks harris is the one
and she said she would love to get him
to america now maria did bring up the
mother of harris's kids
she mentioned that she will eventually
become a problem for stephanie
which again you don't need to be psychic
to see
harris has been on and off with his baby
mama for 14 years now
she is not going anywhere for stephanie
we'll see you soon okay
bye thank you maria have a good night
there we go well what do you think my
father
mary is so good she's so straightforward
and everything but
she thinking like me and the baby mother
still having
a fear and stuff like that what happens
when baby mama
hears you're going to be living the high
life
in the united states me and my baby
mother back and forth back and forth
but right now i'm free and my plan is to
not have another believe genuine
harris might have been able to convince
stephanie in that moment
but next week the issue comes back up
crazy harris
there's a possibility that harris and i
could build a relationship
but i still have a few things weighing
on my mind baby mama i knew
your facebook what tell's this is a
woman who's in love with you
tell me this if the mother of his kids
gets fed up with him and leaves him from
time to time
which harrah said that happens why would
stephanie think things would be better
for her
why money access to america
all of that is going to become a norm
for him eventually if he gets that far
why why would she think that i don't
know 90 day fans fam i guess some
questions we will never have answers to
but in the meantime make sure you stick
with et
because as usual we are covering it all
i'll see you next time
[Music]